I heard that you wear glasses or
contacts both and that you did not wear
them onstage was that you could have
worn contacts without an a choice that
you yeah I don't I mean my visions not
terrible like I can see you I'm not
wearing conscious I'm hard to miss yeah
I mean I'm a big orange parade float
yeah well I don't I don't wear them in
situations like this because I can't
really see y'all anything I mean I know
you're there I can feel your energy but
I couldn't if you really hate what I'm
doing I can't see your face yeah and so
that's that's a very useful thing I
think when you're on stage thank you it
just allows you to use the fourth wall
for what it's for
yeah but that's interesting because I I
have the reverse problem of I can always
if if there's if there's five thousand
people in an audience and there's one
person who's not happy with it I'll I
can see that person that's which I think
is terrible you know and it's usually my
dad yeah and he just comes to a lot of
shows and but I can understand why it
would sort of help you didn't have the
audience just be sort of easy yeah
you're enjoying it enough right now
that's all I care about
you know I've heard that lin-manuel
Miranda played Hamilton obviously and
create the show that he was the opposite
his whole life he could see everybody oh
my god would come backstage and be like
ah can you believe the woman like twelve
rows three from the aisle just like
crumpling her paper like that way no I
have no idea that was that if someone
was on a cell phone they would get
removed because not not because of house
or stage management or anything Lynne
would come backstage and give you the
seat number
it was weird cuz why I remember when I
had this when I saw the show pretty
early in the run I didn't even have
great seats I was way in the back and at
the curtain call he looked he like saw
me and did the little string dance thing
yeah but he looked at me like how the
hell can you even see me back here I was
like way in the back and he can he's
like a I don't know is from magical it's
yeah it's a superpower like for
attention
[Laughter]
you